[Music]
today we cancel mary katherine starr who
is the artist podcaster consultant
professional yoga instructor with
pronouns in her bio though that last
detail i'm sure would
already have been assumed who's amassed
a large online following through her
viral comics depicting motherhood
as she sees it
now if you spend any time on social
media you may have already encountered
one or two or 20 of these mom life
comics where star
shares her relatable insights into
marriage relatable to her anyway and i
suppose to the band of bitter sullen
women who follow her and share her
content it becomes clear rather quickly
after glancing at her work that star
really does not enjoy motherhood very
much doesn't like her husband very much
and is now attempting to make her
resentment seem
inspirational
much of it centers around as a glowing
profile in the huffington post explains
the unfair ways that society views moms
versus dads
except that these viral comics often
seem less relevant to society and more
based on whatever petty gripe she has
about her husband on any particular day
for example
one of her recent offerings which has
circulated widely on social media is
captioned
one of the many differences between me
and my husband
in one panel we see her staring at a
peach on the table and the thought
bubble says oh look the last ripe peach
i'll save it for the kids they love
peaches so much
the next panel shows her husband and his
thought bubble says oh look the last
ripe peach i'll use it as a special
treat in my daily smoothie
now surely her husband deserves this
public shaming for having the audacity
to eat the food in his own house
and he gets shamed for many other things
too in another comic this one with
nearly 20 000 likes on instagram she
tells us the saga
of her husband having trouble finding
things
it says we're sitting down to eat
breakfast my husband is still in the
kitchen i say will you grab a bib for
teddy he says where are the bibs
what i want to say in response is
they're in the same place they've been
for the past five years in the same
place i put them every time i watched
them and put them away presumably the
same place you've gotten them from a
thousand times before unless of course
you've never gotten either one of our
kids a bib in the past five years
but what i actually say in the corner
cabinet the same place they've always
been
and that my friends is called
self-control
nothing like bitching about your spouse
publicly while also congratulating
yourself for being passive-aggressive
oftentimes she seems to make no attempt
to be humorous at all i'm being generous
in assuming that some of this is at
least supposed to be somewhat funny i
guess i don't know
and um
in these other cases she just simply
lectures her husband directly like this
one uh it says me trying to explain our
household dynamics in terms my husband
understands and then we see her saying
on most sports teams you have a
superstar or a playmaker who makes
things happen that's me
then you often have that one person who
just stands around waiting for other
people to make plays or shoot the ball
that's you
we need you to step up so we can win as
a team
now here we see the danger of making a
sports analogy when you've never watched
a single sporting event in your entire
life but we're going to return to that
in just a moment there are many other
examples we don't need to cycle through
she has comments complaining that her
husband doesn't carry as many grocery
bags from the car as she does
another where she complains that her
husband gets to work out alone while she
has to work out with her kids draped all
draped all over her she complains that
um
once he wore a winter hat that was hers
without her permission she has a whole
comic about that
she complains that uh he takes up too
much room on the couch when he naps he
complains that she complains that um he
uh he gets to nap in the first place and
she doesn't she complains that he takes
too long to run errands she has many
comments complaining that her husband
spends too much time going to the
bathroom this is a theme she returns to
over and over again
her husband's defecation habits have
been thoroughly chronicled by this woman
she even has a father's day card that
she's created which centers around this
theme it says
this father's day take as much time as
you need in the bathroom oh wait that's
you every day so this father's day take
as much time as you need in the bathroom
and i promise not to say anything about
it well i'll try my very best
while this is passive-aggressive is it
it's at least a little bit nicer than
the mother's day card that
i wish her husband would give to her
sometime it could say something like
happy mother's day being with you is at
least better than being fed feet first
into a wood chipper
though the wood chipper is looking
better every day
her husband we can assume lacks the
gumption to say anything like that to
her but others on the internet have
spoken up on his behalf suggesting that
maybe she should stop incessantly
whining publicly about her about her
marriage
maybe this is something she could do in
counseling or something
in response to the critics this weekend
she murdered herself some more posting a
defiant response on instagram and
extensively quoting taylor swift lyrics
at the same time and she of course
chalked the criticism up to sexism and
said any that anyone who disagrees with
her approach will be blocked
which certainly is the least
intimidating threat ever issued in the
history of threats
but at the risk of maybe suffering the
same fate i want to offer some thoughts
uh to this woman
about her marriage i mean given that
she's talking publicly about it i guess
it's fair game
first of all um
i don't know how many of these
complaints accurately describe her
husband's behavior
there's no reason to think that any of
them are 100 fair
i i do know that
many of them certainly don't accurately
describe husbands in general as she
claims they do i've never met a man who
doesn't take immense pride in his
ability to transport an entire trunk
full of grocery bags into the kitchen in
one trip that's what men do that's like
we love doing that
as for having kids draped all over you
while exercising i actually encourage my
kids to do that to me because it adds
extra resistance and makes for a more
effective workout also puts them to good
use for a change
it might be true that men take longer to
complete one specific bathroom activity
but this is balanced out by the amount
of time that women take to do everything
else in the bathroom
and and do we as men have a habit of
forgetting where things are in the house
often staring helplessly at our own
kitchen cabinets and pantries as if this
is the first time we've ever laid eyes
on them
yes i mean that stereotype is i admit
richly deserved
but
here's the bigger question
so what
sure mary your husband isn't perfect
no husband is
all husbands are deeply and
irretrievably flawed
yes the rumors are true
as a wife
you will not be able to turn your
husband into a perfect specimen of
faultless
humanity you especially won't be able to
accomplish that by scolding nagging or
whining that approach always and i mean
always has the opposite effect
the only thing you can do
is decide
whether you will obsessively focus on
your husband's flaws or not
you have to decide
if you want to be a martyr
or simply a wife
a martyr or simply a mother
do you want to stew in the juices of
your own resentment constantly adding to
the broth with new groans and gripes
or do you want to actually be happy
and content
or at least have a chance of happiness
and contentment
are you going to be so resentful over
the chores you do around the house that
simply being around you becomes a chore
for everybody else
this is what you have the power to
control
and so does your husband for himself
because despite what you apparently
believe
your husband certainly has a whole
litany of complaints about you
he may not say them out loud very often
or post about them on the internet
because he respects you more than you
respect him but he has them
no husband is perfect yes but neither is
any wife
that's especially true in your case
i wonder have you ever taken a break
during one of your
self-pity sessions
to reflect on the things that you might
be doing wrong
you've devoted hours and days and months
and years to thinking about talking
about crying about
screaming about all the many ways that
you're put upon oppressed unappreciated
but have you ever at any point
allowed for even one second of honest
self-reflection
if you feel that your husband is so
oblivious to his failings that you need
to point them out 75 times a day have
you considered the possibility
that you might suffer from the same
blind spot
or worse are you aware of your failings
and yet you justify them to yourself by
comparing them to your husband's
failings
and if this is the case and i'm certain
that it is have you considered that he
might be doing the same thing perhaps
your marriage is stuck in a cycle of
self-rationalization and self-martyrdom
and it will continue in that circle
all the way around the dream
one other thought
your sports analogy was instructive but
not for the reason that you hoped
you say that there's always uh
the one guy on the team who stands
around doing nothing
now that might be true on amateur teams
like in little league or pop warner or
on the on the detroit lions but in the
big leagues everyone on the field or on
the court is involved
they all have a role
they're all doing something on every
play even if they appear to be doing not
much at all
so someone who doesn't understand
football might watch the action you know
from whistle to whistle and conclude
that the left tackle is mostly just a
spectator but those who know the game
understand that he has an indispensable
role to play even if it's less glamorous
less highlight-worthy
less praised
and even if he tends to only get his
name called when he screws up
in spite of that he's in the trenches on
every play filling a role that no one
else on the team could possibly fill
so i wonder if you might misinterpret
your marriage
in the same way that you misinterpret
football just because you don't
appreciate or understand all the ways
that your husband contributes
that doesn't mean he isn't contributing
i mean this could be less a problem with
his effort and more a problem with your
self-centered refusal to even attempt to
see things from his perspective
you're the superstar the playmaker in
your own mind
and just like any other player who
elevates himself while denigrating his
team
you're doing more harm than good
you're destroying your team in fact
while telling yourself that you're the
only one helping it succeed
so i would recommend that you try
watching a game before saying anything
else about sports and also try looking
in the mirror
before saying anything else about your
marriage
but you don't have to look in the mirror
to know that you are today
still canceled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated